we have a voicemail number that number
is 2192 david p
here's something interesting there's
this uh trumpy right winger
troy york who's been calling into the
show for years
and this is sort of like a last salvo
from troy york as
donald trump is done and joe biden
becomes president
very confused maybe sort of dejected
and just spreading a lot of
disinformation let's listen to a little
bit of it okay take a listen to this
yeah why do you keep saying that
uh red states are the leeches and blue
states pay into more what
what well because that's true talking
about
blue states cost more with the pension
costs okay so that
see then now that blue states cost more
with pension costs
that has nothing to do with what i was
talking about the the frame here
is that if there were to be a civil war
or a secession
now unlike during the civil war
things are less clearly defined because
cities are overwhelmingly left whereas
rural areas are overwhelmingly right but
that if you can come up with a sort of
traditional blue state red state split
the country that would be made up of
american red states would be completely
unsustainable financially because as we
know
when it comes to federal funds paid in
by states or paid out two states the
blue states subsidize the red states
this has nothing to do with
state pensions the the cost for the
storing and locking up criminals um
the cost of big government why do you
keep saying that
the cost of big government yeah it
doesn't really sound like troy york
knows what he's talking about
red states are more sustainable they can
actually
take care of themselves produce food
and and again all of that is very wrong
i mean food is an interesting one
there's no doubt that many red and
purple states are big
food producers but you need only look at
the top food producers of the country to
see that
california produces twice as much food
as any other state and then if you look
at the top 10
there's a bunch of purple and blue
states there you've got california
minnesota and illinois are top food
growers
wisconsin is a top food grower so yeah
sure
many red states produce a lot of food
but
it is not at all clear that uh that they
produce more than
the blue state it on every one of these
things troy is just wrong
boostings are the ones that are
constantly in debt
very much untrue and are mismanaged and
are not financially feasible yeah i mean
it's so that's literally the opposite of
the truth as we've
we've looked at many times um there are
many more red states that without being
on federal welfare essentially money
from the federal government
there are many blue states that would be
sustainable there are very few red
states that would and
i don't know that the facts really
matter to a lot of these folks and
that's why tomorrow
we will be going through in detail or
friday it depends if i have time
a very interesting right wing focus
group
with trump voters done by frank luntz
we have a fantastic bonus show today and
it's inauguration day it may already
have happened
by the time you listen to today's show
tomorrow full
wall-to-wall coverage of the joe biden
inauguration
of the trumpian right-wing meltdown of
the future of joe biden's day one
priorities yes we will be covering them
and so much more get instant access
to the david pakman show membership
program and today's great bonus show
by signing up at joinpackman.com